ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
ce matin les sénateurs ont adopté le
projet de loi qui met en place des jurés
populaires dans les tribunaux
correctionnels et qui réforme en
profondeur la justice des mineurs parmi
les mesures votées par les sénateurs la
possibilité d'une comparution immédiate
sur convocation d'un officier de police
judiciaire pour les mineurs de moins de
16 ans et la création d'un tribunal
correctionnel pour les mineurs de moins
de 16 ans récidiviste c'est d'ailleurs
le vote de ces deux mesures que je vous
propose de revoir tout de suite bonne
science à tous nous en ont maintenant
aux articles 17 et 29 appelé par
priorité à l'article 17
monsieur michel vous avez demandé la
parole oui merci madame la présidente
m'a prise de parole concerne en fait
titre 2 la commission a souhaité que des
articles en avant pour des questions je
dirais de cohérence mais je vais faire
une intervention général sur ce titre 2
qui concerne la justice des mineurs et
ensuite on nous pensons que si ce texte
était abordé par le parlement ait été
validé et validés par le conseil
constitutionnel
il signifierait la démolition de
l'ambiance de 45
or laurence de 45 il faut le savoir elle
a été promulguée par le général de
gaulle qui programment et solennellement
il est peu de problèmes aussi graves que
ce qui concerne la protection de
l'enfance et parmi eux ceux qui ont
trait au sort de l'enfance traduites en
justice
faut replacer ces phrases dans leur
contexte historique et dans le contexte
de la personne qui les a prononcés qui
peut être avait d'autres idées en tête à
ce moment là mais il a dit la crise a
depuis d'ailleurs la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant
ratifiée par la france dans son article
40 prescrit également qu'il faut tenir
compte de l'âge de l'enfant
pour faciliter sa réintégration dans la
société et la minorité en france est
déterminée par l'antique 388 du code
civil
le mineur
et l'individu de l'or ou l'autre sexe
qui n'a pas encore l'âge de 18 ans
accomplis
donc de ce point de vue là tout et c'est
pour faire basculer la majorité plus bas
à 16 ans par exemple la minorité est un
échec de notre avis est
inconstitutionnelle
plus récemment d'ailleurs le comité des
droits de l'enfant des nations unies a
préconisé le changement des lois qui
traitent les majeures des mineurs comme
les majeures en réaffirmant l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant qui doit être une
considération primordiale
or le projet de loi qui nous est soumis
monsieur le ministre
ces cartes des principes fondamentaux
posés par le conseil constitutionnel et
surtout et surtout venant de vous
personnellement car là c'est à regarder
ce que je m'adresse michel mercier
eh bien ils s'éloignent de la
philosophie qui a inspiré la france
depuis 45
car à l'époque qui a été à la base de
l'endurance de 45 ce qu'on appelait les
démocrates chrétiens
le garde des sceaux était à nouveau
illustre ancêtre pierre henri teitgen
les magistrats s'étaient pierre ancel
les usant des enfants qui à cette époque
on construit le droit des mineurs par
leurs pratiques
je vais en citer quelques-uns c'était
pierre marc tadié à bordeaux c'était
pierre savigneau c'était henry gaillac
des hommes qui ont passé toute leur vie
toute leur vie dans la magistrature sans
avancement pratiquement pour la défense
de leurs mille ans de 45 de la
protection des enfants tantôt pénale que
ensuite dans l'ordre de 58 pour
l'assistance éducative
or aujourd'hui vous fait litière de tout
cela et vous vous rapprochez
ostensiblement du droit des majeures
d'abord on le verra tout à l'heure à
laissant même par une espèce de
comparution immédiate des mineurs devant
un tribunal correctionnel
nouveau or aujourd'hui on sait que les
mineurs avant d'être traduit pénalement
sont suivis par des éducateurs et
qu'ensuite devant le juge des enfants
seuls dans son cabinet ou devant le
tribunal on a un rapport ce qu'ils ont
fait depuis leurs actes de délinquance
là tout ça est balayé deuxièmement vous
instituez un nouveau tribunal pour les
16 18 ans troisièmement vous remplacer
un certain nombre
de mesures éducatives par par des peines
tout ceci nous paraît totalement
contraire à la philosophie et aux
dispositions de l'ordonnancé de 45 et
également aux dernières décisions du
conseil constitutionnel
même si vous prétendez le contraire et
vous allez prétendre le contraire
monsieur le garde des sceaux à l'effet à
l'occaison la loi perben
1 le conseil constitutionnel le 29 août
2002 a reconnu le principe fondamental
de la justice des mineurs
la loi du 12 avril 2006 à la majorité
pénale
la loi du 22 juillet 2012 se développe
aux enfants l'ordonnancé dès février 45
ces textes pour le conseil
constitutionnel sont intangibles dans
leur philosophie or voulait bousculer
assez confortablement et ensuite tout
dernièrement le conseil constitutionnel
a encore repris cette jurisprudence pour
affirmer que un essai de comparution
immédiate des mineurs étaient
inconstitutionnels vous le reprenez tout
autre terme
mais tout ceci veine fait illusion à
personne vous êtes en dehors des règles
et vous êtes en dehors surtout monsieur
le ministre de la philosophie qui a
inspiré les principes leur donnant du 10
février 45 priorité à l'éducatif avant
tout car il s'agit pas d' éviter la
récidive des mineurs
il s'agit d'éviter que les mineurs tombe
dans la délinquance c'est quand même de
cela dont il faudrait parler d'abord
professionnels spécialisés autour de
l'enfant or la comparution immédiate par
un officier de police judiciaire
on ne parle absolument plus des
professionnels spécialisés traitement
personnalisé du suivi de l'enfant
on n'a pas absolument plus ni dans la
comparution immédiate ni dans la
nouvelle juridiction tout vous instituez
recours exceptionnel et limité à la
détention
on verra au cours des articles que ce
n'est pas le cas donc tout ceci nous
éloigne considérablement des principes
qui ont juste ici régit la justice des
mineurs et nous rapproche
malheureusement je dirais de la justice
des mineurs qui a cours notamment aux
états unis amérique qui peut être une
grande démocratie mais qui en matière de
justice encore beaucoup de progrès à
faire
il monsieur michel trois hommes trois
amendements identiques faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 31
merci oui comme vient de le dire notre
collègue nous arrivons ici un volet
important celui de la jugement des
mineurs
un volet d'autant plus important que
malheureusement il est resté et nous le
regrettons assez ignorée par tout le
monde et en particulier par les médias
je vous rappelle que l'article 41 de la
loi loppsi 2 introduisez un article 8,3
au sein de l' ordonnance de 45 prévoyant
que le procureur de la république pour
suivre un mineur devant un tribunal pour
enfants
selon la procédure prévue à l'article
390 1 du code de procédure pénale
citation à personne par greffier sur
rouleaux pj sur instruction du procureur
de la république
si des investigations supplémentaires
sur les faits ne sont pas nécessaires et
que des investigations sur la
personnalité du mineur ont été accomplis
le cas échéant à l'occasion d'une
procédure engagée dans les six mois
précédant ou d'une procédure ayant donné
lieu à une condamnation dans les six
mois précédant le conseil
constitutionnel a considéré dans sa
décision du 10 mars 2011 que ces
dispositions sont applicables à tous les
mineurs quel que soit l'âge les dates
caisses l'état du casier judiciaire
la gravité de l'infraction poursuivie
qu'elle ne garantissent pas que le
tribunal dispose grade informations
récentes sur la personnalité du mineur
lui permettant de rechercher son
relèvement éducatif et moral que par
suite elles méconnaissent les exigences
constitutionnelles en matière de justice
pénale des mineurs
il a déclaré cet article contraire à la
constitution
le présent article propose une nouvelle
procédure censée tenir compte des
observations de la décision de cette de
la dernière décision du conseil
constitutionnel
elle prévoit que le procureur de la
république poursuivre devant le tribunal
pour enfants ce toujours selon les
termes de l'article 390 1
du code de procédure pénale des mineurs
âgés d'au moins 13 ans lorsqu'il est
reproché d'avoir commis des délits punis
de cinq ans d'emprisonnement et des
mineurs de moins 16 ans lorsqu'il leur
est reproché d'avoir commis des délits
punis de plus de trois ans
d'emprisonnement
la convocation est délivré aux mineurs
par un officier de police judiciaire
dans les locaux du commissariat soit
directement après une période garde à
vue soit après que ce dernier a été
invité à se présenter en vue de la
remise de cette convocation
la convocation ne peut être délivré que
si des investigations sur les faits ne
sont pas nécessaires et si les
investigations sur la personnalité du
mineur ont été accomplis le cas échéant
selon la procédure de l'article 12
le rapport a établi par la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse
à la demande du procureur de la
république du juge des enfants ou de la
juridiction d'instruction contenant tous
les renseignements utiles sur la
situation du mineur ainsi qu'une
proposition éducative à l'occasion d'une
procédure en cours une procédure
antérieure à un an
le mineur doit être assistée d'un avocat
désigné par lui ou commis d'office
la convocation est adressé aux mineurs
et aux parents tuteurs ou personnes au
service duquel le mineur est confiée
quant à l'audience elle doit se tenir
dans un délai qui ne peut pas être
inférieure à 10 jours est supérieure à
deux mois cette prose et procédures qui
existent pour les majeurs consiste pour
le parquet affaires convoqué en justice
un mineur de moins de 13 ans lorsqu'il
lui est reproché d'avoir commis un délit
puni de cinq ans donc si le procureur
choisi ce mode de saisine du tribunal
c'est dans le but de favoriser valoriser
une comparution immédiate du mineur
puisque l'audience doit se tenir dans un
délai qui me est inférieur à dix jours
ainsi là on s'aperçoit que ce dispositif
se calque sur la procédure pénale
applicable aux majeurs donc on voit que
par cette procédure que l'excusé de
minorité n'existe plus par ailleurs le
recueil de renseignements de l'article
12 ne constitue pas une investigation
mais une simple enquête rapide et il se
résume souvent un simple entretien avec
le mineur au dépôt d'une rencontre avec
les parts
très judicieusement monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez préféré le recueil
de renseignements à l'article 12 de
l'article 12 à celui de l'article 8 plus
complet et nous ne pouvons que le
regretter
merci merci l'amendement 71 madame
mathon poinat oui merci madame la
présidente
alors cet article entend généraliser la
convocation des mineurs par officier de
police judiciaire devant le tribunal
pour enfants en lieu place d'une
procédure de convocation devant le juge
des enfants et se prennent donc la phase
d'instruction du juge afin de favoriser
une convocation rapide
ce à quoi à l'instar du conseil
constitutionnel nous sommes fermement
opposés
la loppsi prévoyait déjà qu'une
procédure de citation directe proche de
la comparution immédiate pourrait être
utilisé à l'encontre des mineurs jusqu'à
lors le droit pénal des mineurs écartait
toute procédure immédiate même si de
réforme de 2002 puis de 2007 permettait
de juger dans un délai déjà réduit à dix
jours sous certaines conditions
dès lors que les auteurs sont connus et
les faits établis pour autant le conseil
constitutionnel s'est opposé à ce volet
de la loppsi et à une justice expéditive
ne permettant pas de prendre en compte
les évolutions du mineur et le contexte
éducatif dans lequel il évolue
malgré cette défaite constitutionnel le
gouvernement a donc décidé de passer
outre et de trouver de nouvelles pistes
d'accélération de la justice des mineurs
dans le même souci d'accélérer ses
procédures le texte propose d'insérer
dans l' ordonnance de 1945 un article 8
3 aux fins de permettre la convocation
par officier de police judiciaire devant
ce tribunal pour enfants sera donc
concerner le mineurs âgés d'au moins 13
ans lorsqu'il lui est reproché d'avoir
commis un délit puni de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement
ainsi qu'aux mineurs d'au moins 16 ans
lorsqu'il lui est reproché d'avoir
commis un délit puni de trois ans
d'emprisonnement
si les faits sont établis et si des
investigations sur la personnalité du
mineur ou été accompli à l'occasion de
la procédure en cours ou d'une procédure
antérieure de
donnant l'audience se tiendra dans un
délai qui ne peut être inférieure à 10
jours est supérieure à deux mois
a contrario le projet propose de
supprimer cette procédure rapide datant
de 1995
la convocation par officier de police
judiciaire aux fins de jugement devant
le juge des enfants
et il faut dire que cette procédure ne
présentent pas l'intérêt ce père et part
seul au gouvernement puisque le juge des
enfants
ainsi saisi ne peut prononcer que des
mesures éducatives et ne peut pas
condamner à une peine
bref en supprimant la possibilité
d'avoir recours à cette procédure vous
voulez frappé un peu plus vite et
peut-être un peu plus fort nous ne
voulons pas de cette justice expéditive
et l'otan - qu'elle s'adresse aux
mineurs donc nous vous demandons la
suppression de cet article
merci le 137e rectifié monsieur lézard
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est aussi
un amendement de suppression de cet
article 17
avec lequel nous entamons l'examen des
dispositions relatives à la justice des
mineurs
et avec la 35e modifications depuis l'
ordonnance du 2 février 1945
nous savons tous ici que ce droit pénal
des mineurs est strictement encadrée par
le conseil constitutionnel qui l'a
encore rappelé il y à peu par trois
grands principes priorité de l'éducatif
avant tout jugement spécialisation des
juridictions et mise en oeuvre plus
protectrice de la loi et de la procédure
pénale
or cet article 17 donne un aperçu tout à
fait contestable de la mise en oeuvre de
ces trois grands principes
nous y voyons par exemple la suppression
de la convocation par au pgi et devant
le juge des enfants au profit de son
institution devant le tribunal pour
enfants ce qui est tout à fait
inopportun et je dois dire que ajouté à
la procédure de présentation immédiate
ce système confère de faits au parquet
la maîtrise de l'audiencement devant les
juridictions pour mineurs tribunal pour
enfants et nouveau tribunal
correctionnel des mineurs
de ce fait le juge des enfants perd
toute prérogative lui permettant de
devancer au tribunal pour enfants en
fonction des priorités alors que c'est
quand même le juge des enfants qui
connaît le mieux les dossiers des
enfants parce qu il les suit soit au
pénal soit en assistance éducative et de
ce fait nous avons des choix qui
s'effectueront en opportunité est
malheureusement sans une cohérence
globale donc là c'est un choix que vous
réalisez en fait et j'y reviendrai
peut-être en explications de vote
il s'agit de quoi de dire qu' il y a une
grande augmentation de la délinquance
délire ce qui est inexact vue au vu des
chiffres par rapport à la à la
délinquance en général et c'est un choix
au moment où nous avons où nous devrions
avoir tous ces débats sur le statut du
parquet d'un choix de donner pouvoir le
choix d'opportunité que le parquet soit
on le dit souvent le juge de
l'opportunité des poursuites
soit c'est une tradition de notre droit
pénal mais là vous allez plus loin et je
ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne chose
donc
en vertu de ces considérations là en
plus par le fait que cet article 17 vise
tous les mineurs de plus 13 ans à
l'encontre de qui une peine peut être
prononcée qui a aucune distinction selon
la gravité de l'infraction et que la
cop10 pourra être mise en oeuvre à
l'encontre du multirécidiviste comme du
primo délinquants sandra dation
distinction nous pensons là haut rang là
encore que c'est une mauvaise innovation
contraire d'ailleurs à la tradition de
notre droit et monsieur le ministre
être soucieux
des traditions des grands principes de
notre droit c'est faire preuve de bon
conservatisme car cela peut exister et
vous en êtes souvent l'illustration
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
l'article 17 du projet de loi que ces
trois amendements souhaite supprimer
madame la présidente temps d'une part à
supprimer la procédure de convocation
par officier de police judiciaire devant
le juge des enfants enfin de jugement et
d'autre part à créer une procédure de
cop10 devant le tribunal pour enfants la
suppression de la procédure de ces au
psg aux fins de jugement introduite en
96 se justifie par le fait qu'elle est
peu utilisée en outre le juge des
enfants a la possibilité
lorsqu'il met le mineur en examen de le
juger en cours de procédure et de
prononcer à son encontre une ou
plusieurs mesures éducatives
il y avait donc redondance le texte
clarifie les choses
la création d'une procédure de ces au
psg devant le tribunal pour enfants
permettra quant à elle d'accélérer le
jugement des mineurs
déjà bien connu de l'autorité judiciaire
je précise qu'à la différence de la
procédure de présentation immédiate
il n'est pas prévu de pouvoir placer
deux mineurs sous contrôle judiciaire ou
en détention provisoire en attendant
l'audience de jugement
enfin votre commission a bien précisé
que cette procédure ne pourrait être
mise en oeuvre que lorsque la
juridiction dispose d'investigations
approfondies et récentes sur la
personnalité du mineur et non d'un seul
rse recueil de renseignements socio
éducatif il semble à votre commission qu
ainsi défini ces dispositions permettent
de garantir un équilibre satisfaisant
entre l'exigence de célérité de la
réponse pénale et le respect des
principes constitutionnels applicables
au droit pénal des mineurs
la vie et donc défavorable pour les
trois banques messier leurs machines
ministre même avait jeu avant de mettre
aux voix y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote mal à mme claisse
merci madame la présidente je voulais
faire quelques quelques remarques et
peut-être apporter quelques chiffres au
débat au jour d'aujourd'hui c'est une
mesure telle qu'elle nous est présentée
qui serait certainement beaucoup plus
appliquée qui sera certainement beaucoup
plus appliquée qu'en 96 puisque par le
jeu et le biais de l'ensemble des
réformes et du durcissement du code de
procédure pénal auquel on a assisté ces
dernières années c'est 75% des mineurs
délinquants qui serait concerné par cet
article aujourd'hui est donc 75 % ça ne
me paraît pas anecdotique
ça c'est la première remarque je voulais
faire
la deuxième remarque que je voulais
faire c'est qu'il n'est pas anormal
qu'un enfant est ce qu'on parle de
mineure mais peut-être quand même se
rappeler que les mineurs se sont d'abord
des enfants qui sont des adultes en
devenir est en construction il donc pas
anormal qu'il se construise par des
tentatives de transgression de
l'interdît
il est donc tout à fait normal d'y
répondre d'abord par l'intermédiaire des
parents et s'ils sont défaillants ou six
ont besoin d'une aide supplémentaire par
l'intermédiaire de la société
cependant la réponse se doit d'être
adapté aux faits réels et se doit
d'abord d'être avisé éducatif qui
commence est un petit peu moins le cas
dans le texte qui nous est présenté
aujourd'hui
l'autre remarque que je voulais faire
c'est que la présentation de ce texte
mais connaît manifestement les
caractéristiques de la récidive des
mineurs en fait
75% des mineurs délinquants ne sont vu
qu'une fois ne sont vu qu'une fois par
les services de la justice 5% seulement
des mineurs délinquants deviennent des
majeurs délinquants 5% des enfants
délinquants deviennent des adultes
délinquants donc pour 5 % d'enfants
délinquants pour lequel le système
aujourd'hui en place se révèle
défaillant
on est en train de mettre en place un
système qui concernera demain
75 % des enfants délinquants j'y vois
moi en incohérence est en tout cas le
risque fort de l'inutilité et de
l'inefficacité du système qu'on est en
train de mettre en place
indépendamment du fait que l'on bafoue
la le droit des enfants et que l'on
bafoue la nécessité de la prévalence de
l'éducatif sur le répressif 75 % des
enfants et on va donc mettre dans un
système calqué sur le système réservé
aux adultes
75 % des enfants délinquants alors que
le système des adultes lui a fait la
preuve de son efficacité
puisque 75 % des adultes eux récidive
madame la présidente
le borvo cohen seat merci madame la
présidente je crois que c'est que les
dispositifs que vous préconisez qui
rapproche les procédures mineurs des
procédures pour marcheurs et sont
sous-tendues quand même par chez dans
votre esprit
on va dire par des que les justice des
mineurs est donc et juge pour enfants
sont trop indulgent qu'ils ont une
vision ancienne de l'enfance de la
jeunesse ou des mineurs on connaît les
qualificatifs que vous aimez
employés à leur sujet a fait pas
forcément vous monsieur le ministre mais
enfin certains et donc qu'il faut
absolument pousser à ce que les mineurs
soient jugés très rapidement et est une
sanction pénale le plus rapidement
possible alors évidemment cela serait
pourrait être entendu si on pensait que
ça avait une efficacité
or bien entendu monsieur le rapporteur
vous connaissez suffisamment les
professionnels d'ailleurs vous les avez
entendus 5 août est pour le moins
entendu je ne sais pas écoutez comme moi
et ils disent tout le contraire ils
disent même que un mineur qui est entré
à un moment donné dans la délinquance
on peut considérer déjà d'une part qui
lie peut-être rentrer mais qui lit pas
rentrer pour toujours parce qu'il ya
aussi quand même répandu l'idée que
quand on est rentré dans la délinquance
on en sort plus donc du coup
voyez après que faire bon voilà et met
donc des mineurs qui sont très en
délinquance au fond on préfère
finalement être jugé très rapidement
éventuellement aller la case prison dont
il mesure semble pas ce qu'il en est
plutôt que d'être pris en charge sur la
durée dans la perspective de les sortir
précisément de la délinquance donc je
crois qu et les réflexions que font les
professionnels
ça paraît si nantes mais en tout cas le
mérite d'être entendu et je crois
d'ailleurs que pour ceux qui ont vu des
mineurs enfermés délinquante donc
enfermé que ce soit d'ailleurs en
centres éducatifs fermés ou en prison
devrait réfléchir quand même à ce qui se
passe parce que vous savez on a fermé
les centres de rééducation il n'y a pas
si longtemps historiquement ont fait il
ya déjà quelques décennies pour des
raisons qui peuvent se reproduire
aujourd'hui et qui se reproduisent bien
souvent d'ailleurs dans les lieux fermés
pour les mineurs et en plus chacun sait
aussi que la prison est peut-être
éducative du katri ce entre guillemets
pour les mineures mais pas dans le bon
sens voyez donc je crois que si on
cherche vraiment à prendre en charge les
jeunes qui à un moment donné ont commis
des actes délictueux même grave si on
cherche à faire en sorte qu'ils ne
soient pas des délinquants qui se
prolonge et qu'ils puissent avoir une
possibilité de devenir des adultes
inséré dans la société un jour ou
l'autre ou en tout cas qu'il ne soit
plus délinquants je crois que ça mérite
quand même qu'on prenne le temps de
réfléchir plutôt que de dire pour encore
une fois par volonté d'affichage que on
va voir ce qu'on va voir
et nous on va les punir le plus
rapidement possible et on va les envoyer
à la case prison
le plus rapidement possible merci madame
la présidente tasca
merci madame la présidente beaucoup de
raisons juridiques constitutionnel
historique nous conduisent à récuser cet
article 17 est votre conception nouvelle
de la justice des mineurs mais je
voudrais ajouter à ces raisons le refus
qui est le nôtre de la vision que ce
texte propose de l'enfance de l'enfance
et de l'adolescence
c'est une vision à la fois de peur comme
si notre société était en total défense
à l'égard de ses enfants délinquants
c'est aussi une vision d'abandon à
partir du moment où vous alignez la
justice pour mineurs sur la justice pour
adultes ça veut dire que vous gommer
toutes les chances de cette période de
la vie de se rattraper d'évoluer de
changer
et dieu sait que tous ceux ici qui ont
des enfants savent à quel point leur
personne bouge
d'un mois à l'autre d'une année à
l'autre donc vous nous proposer une
vision absolument fermer fermé sans
espoir je voudrais vous dire la
contradiction que je vois entre cette
démarche d'alignement sur la justice des
mineurs et le comportement général de
notre société qui en raison de ses
difficultés économiques et sociales
aujourd'hui reporte de plus en plus tard
l'entrée de nos enfants dans l'
autonomie dans la responsabilité dans la
vie active
mineur il leur est bien au delà dans les
faits bien au delà des 18 ans et ap
absolument contre leur propre volonté
donc on leur dit à travers ce texte
mineur vous pouvez rester jusqu'à 20 ans
25 ans vous découvrirez les minima
sociaux avant d'avoir une quelconque
véritable insertion dans la société
et en même temps on leur dit mineur vous
pouvez cessé de l'être à 13 ans à 16 ans
parce que notre société a peur de vous
et n'est pas capable d'assumer le double
devoir de protection et d'éducation qui
est à la base de l'ordonnancé de 1945
mais qui aujourd'hui devrait être encore
plus présente dans notre vision
justement de l'enfance et de
l'adolescence je crois que nous n'avons
pas le droit monsieur le garde des
sceaux d'opérer ce glissement insidieux
vers la justice des des majeurs la
délinquance des mineurs est une vraie
préoccupation dans notre société ce
n'est pas ça que nous sommes en train de
nier la nécessité de la sanction de
mesures éducatives nous la connaissons
tous nous la reconnaissons mais ce que
nous affirmons en refusant cet article
comme nous refuserons d'ailleurs
d'autres articles de ce titre 2 ce que
nous refusons c'est de fermer la porte
et de quitter une justice spécialisée
pour se rapprocher de la justice des
adultes les enfants ont droit à ce temps
de la vie ils ont droit à cet âge d'être
traités comme des mineurs et pas comme
des majeurs menthe monsieur jean pierre
sueur merci madame la présidente je ne
serai pas intervenu si monsieur le garde
des sceaux n'avait pas prof épreuve à
l'instant de ce laconisme puisqu'il n'a
apporté aucun argument en réponse aux
interventions de mes collègues et tout
particulièrement celle de jean-pierre
michel qui a insisté sur la tradition
humaniste qui avait produisent cette
ordonnance de 1945
monsieur mercier
à côté du parc du luxembourg au jardin
du luxembourg au xviiie siècle et même
au xviie siècle existait une rue qui
s'appelait la rue d'enfer ça donnait
denfert rochereau et cette russe appelée
la rue d'enfer parce qu'il y avait
énormément de banditisme et il y avait
beaucoup de guet-apens et il y avait
même monsieur le ministre la délinquance
juvénile
c'est un sujet qui est très ancien qui a
toujours existé et la question est de
savoir finalement l'idée que son son
qu'on se fait de l'enfant est à cet
égard on pourrait tout à fait citer en
particulier jean jacques rousseau
mais pas seulement est-ce que l'enfance
est une sorte de sauvages eux qui
seraient susceptibles de commettre un
certain nombre d'actes irréfléchis et
qu'il faudrait sanctionner sans pour
autant se préoccuper d'éducation on voit
bien quelle est la philosophie de ce
texte monsieur le garde des sceaux
je m'étonne que vous le défendiez avec
cette comparution immédiate
appelons les choses par leur nom avec
cette substitution du parquet au juge
des enfants
appelons les choses par leur nom avec ce
refus finalement de la spécialisation de
la justice des mineurs du calq de la
justice des mineurs sur la justice des
majeurs vous tourner complètement le dos
à l'ordonance de 45g d'y visiter eux la
maison d'arrêt dans ma ville j'ai
rencontré les représentants des juges
pour enfants de mon département
avez vous fait une concertation monsieur
le ministre avec les juges pour enfants
lorsqu'on voit le travail extraordinaire
qu'ils assument malgré la faiblesse des
moyens on est très étonné de ce que vous
nous asséner peut-être
vous en service commandé monsieur le
garde des sceaux mais franchement il y a
des moments où vous devriez dire non
voilà et je vous explique encore quelque
chose
l' ordonnance de 45
elle n'est pas contre la sanction la
sanction et éducative elle fait partie
de l'éducation vous le savez mais elle
considère que le mineur est un être en
devenir et aux biens l'on n'accepte cela
et l'on tire toute une série de
conséquences
comme d'ailleurs l'a très bien dit le
conseil constitutionnel le 10 mars 2011
à propos de l'article 41 de la loi
loppsi et vous essayez de manière
quelque peu besogneuse de contourner
cette disposition mais vous ne pouvez en
mai connaître ni la lettre ni l'esprit
ou bien on considère finalement qu'il
n'y a plus de spécificité à la justice
pour mineurs et vous êtes sur ce terrain
et ce terrain c'est quoi finalement
protéger la société contre ces sauvages
ces monstres les juges évite les
enfermer vite s'en protéger vite comme
s'il était un poison pour le corps
social
mais ce poison ce sont nos enfants et
par conséquent il y a dans cet article
une conception de l'humanisme et une
conception de la société
tout est difficile et la tâche des juges
pour enfants elle est très difficile
comme la tâche des éducateurs
mais de même que je n'ai pas accepté
dans cet hémicycle que l'on renonce à
des exigences en matière d'éducation
quand par exemple on à céder à la
démagogie de supprimer l'école le samedi
de la vraie démagogie moi je crois qu'il
faut de l'effort pour l'éducation
eh bien il faut aussi de l'effort il
faut beaucoup de travail il faut
beaucoup de ténacité
beaucoup d'oeuvres humaines pour éduquer
ses enfants qui vont mal qui commettent
des délits en effet et c'est toute une
philosophie qui est en cause
monsieur le ministre et vous ne pouvez
pas vous réfugier dans le laconisme il
faut que vous ne répondiez sur le fond
et que vous nous disiez comment vous
argumentez ce changement de philosophie
car c'est bien d'un changement de
philosophie qu'il s'agit si monsieur
pignard
la présence de ces ministres je ne suis
pas membre de la commission des lois et
je ne pensais pas intervenir ce soir
mais j'ai entendu les arguments
développés par monsieur michel madame
tasca par moi même et ses soeurs et
notamment un qui nous on sort de la loi
pour évoquer la philosophie si j'ai bien
compris et j'ai bien entendu tout ce qui
a été dit sur la démocratie chrétienne
en 1945 alors comme je me flatte d'être
aussi dans cet hémicycle un des
représentants de la démocratie
chrétienne je voudrais quand même
répondre sur certains points concernant
la philosophie ce texte
d'abord je crois que c'est une évidence
pour personne nous ne sommes plus en
1945 et nous ne sommes plus en 1945 non
madame et j'adhère aux propos j'adhère
aux propos qu'a dit madame tasca on ne
l'est pas de deux façons
parce qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes de 18
ans comme son ne sont plus des enfants
soyons clairs avec le mode de vie qu'ils
ont avec la nouvelle même physiquement
même physiquement quand vous le parler
et en même temps les jeunes ils sont
effectivement plus enfants que ce 1945
parce qu'en 1945 pour des tas de raisons
les gens travaillaient il y avait 80 %
de la classe d'âge qui travaillait à
partir de 14 15 ans et que ceux qui
étaient des délinquants
c'était précisément parce qu'il se
situer hors de ce système que nous avons
changé du tout au tout et qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons eu ce débat aussi à propos
des retraites
je veux bien qu'on évoque à tous à tout
moment le conseil national de la
résistance et j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour ce qui s'est fait pendant ce
conseil soit y avait aussi des
démocrates chrétiens mais le conseil
national la résistance était 1945
l'ordonance c'était 1945 alors à partir
de là il y avait deux façons de procéder
c'était de faire excuser moi comme si on
était toujours en 1945 et de ne rien
changer
et puis il y avait toute façon alors
disons la façon sécuritaire qui
désireront on va tout on va s'occuper
uniquement de la société pas des jeunes
pour ça c'était très simple il fallait
baisser l'âge de la majorité
et c'est ce que justement je crois
savoir rester exposés au début de ce
débat
le gouvernant n'a pas voulu alors entre
le rien faire et entre faire comme si
rien n'avait changé je crois qu'à une
voie médiane alors c'est peut-être une
voix démocrate chrétienne c'était une
voix centristes et peut-être tout ce que
vous voulez mais je crois qu'on ne peut
pas l'y nier cette réalité
et puis je devrais dire quand même à
monsieur sûr si vous permettez sait que
sa façon de dire le tout répressif qui
remplace le tout éducatif
moi je vais vous dire il ya quand même
une chose qui a changé aussi 1945
je ne sais plus si vous êtes ou si vous
l'avez été dans un conseil général
je ne pense pas qu'en 1945 les conseils
généraux dépenser autant d'argent qu'il
n'en dépense aujourd'hui pour la
protection de l'enfance et je peux vous
dire et croyez moi je comprends votre
expression ne suis pas en service
commandé
mais je peux témoigner ici pour être y
semant du conseil général depuis 20 ans
aux côtés de michel mercier que le
département du rhône consacre un budget
énorme pour la protection de l'enfance
et que je peux pas laisser dire ce soir
que c'est tout répressif par rapport à
tout éducatif mais je suis navré il ya
un moment il ya une limite dans le too
d'éducatif et il faut aussi lorsque
cette limite a été franchie lorsque la
société a mis tout l'argent et tout le
talent qu'elle avait pour essayer de
faire quelque chose à un moment aussi où
la justice doit dire son mot monsieur
charles gautier madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je suis très heureux par les hasards des
inscriptions d'intervenir après ce que
je viens d'entendre
lorsque l'on évoque les ordonnances de
parmi tous ceux qui on parle il ya
toujours en gros deux catégories il ya
ceux qui parlent de 45 de cette volonté
d'apporter une réponse à un problème
précis
est ce un problème existait
c'est aussi une réponse à ceux qui
considèrent que la jeunesse
d'aujourd'hui a tous les défauts et que
dans le temps ça se passait très bien
si on a fait des ordonnances en 45 c'est
qu'ils avaient besoin d'en faire
il y avait de vrais problèmes et entre
45 aujourd'hui à chacune des époques on
a connu des catégories de jeunes qui
venaient justement apporter leurs
troubles à l' équilibre de la société et
en 45 dans une volonté généreuse qui
était celle qui inspirait d'ailleurs
toutes les initiatives de ce moment là
en direction des jeunes
il ya eu une volonté de ne pas rejeter
cette tranche d'âge à un moment où
justement se mettait en place
beaucoup d'institutions pour l'ensemble
de la société
et puis il y a ceux qui parlent de 45
comme je viens d'entendre le dire mais
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
ceux d'hier 45
ça fait 65 ans 60 ans et plus faites le
calcul a évidemment évidemment que les
jeunes aiment un tout ça ça a changé
notre société a changé et c'est parce
que ça a changé qu'il faudrait qu'on
change tout mais messieurs mesdames
mes chers amis essayez de regarder ce
qui s'est passé depuis 1945 par rapport
à ces textes là il y a déjà eu près
d'une quarantaine de modification il n'y
a pas une ligne qu'ils soient d'origine
il n'en reste que le titre il en reste
le titre donc
donc vous voyez 45 on en parle
soit pour avoir un idéal soit pour se
camoufler pour avoir au contraire de
mauvaises arrière-pensée et ses
arrière-pensées d'aujourd'hui
effectivement nous ne partageons pas
nous ne partageons pas parce que
justement la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui ne
mérite pas ça certes tout le monde peut
être témoin je le disais dans une
intervention
précédent peut-être avec moins de
solennité mais tout le monde est témoin
du fait que les jeunes sont sans doute
adolescents plus tôt mais après quelles
difficultés
quels obstacles à surmonter
et pour devenir adulte je crois
justement que on devient adulte
peut-être un peu plus tard même si la
société reconnaît un certain nombre de
droits la majorité beaucoup de choses
mais tout à l'heure dans l'après midi et
un amendement leur art de notre
organisation fait que ce mois qu'il est
proposé c'est un des rares
j'en suis satisfait qui fut acceptée par
la majorité
c'était justement sur la sphère des
jurés qu'on n'aille pas chercher jusqu'à
18 ans cette fixation du 18 ans et donc
on est resté je crois 23 ans dans un
consensus l'assemblée
et bien moi ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que aujourd'hui en demandant en
exigeant que on a toujours cherché chez
des plus jeunes une équivalence à des
adultes à des sanctions qui seraient les
mêmes nous faisons fausse route et nous
sommes d'ailleurs les seuls à faire
cette route
je dois quand même vous dire que si on
regarde nos amis européens
un pays comme l'espagne un pays comme
l'allemagne dans cette démocratie là il
est en train de se préparer justement un
certain nombre de textes pour lesquels
ils porteraient jusqu'à 21 ans le statut
des mineurs par rapport au pénal voilà
je vous lève seulement vous
nous on a le droit d'être aveuglé et
puis de continuer comme ça au cours
d'une nuit printanière de vouloir
apporter des réponses à celles ceux qui
attendent des preuves d'une musculation
par rapport à l'organisation de notre
société ça vous remercie merci monsieur
lézard
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
dans un débat véritablement de fond de
principe
j'ai entendu la référence à la
démocratie chrétienne shera à notre
garde des sceaux et croit que les
principes qui étaient ceux qui ont
poussé le législateur en 1900 l'exécutif
surtout en 1945 aller dans ce sens sans
ce qu'on peut appeler des principes
fondamentaux fondateur même s'il est
exact cette ordonnance
il n'en reste dans la réalité pas grand
chose dans antho au niveau littérale par
rapport à ce qu'elle était en 1945 y
compris l'article 1 qui a été modifié
dès 1951
ceci étant les principes il est dans
notre république bien heureusement des
principes fondateurs qui remettrait en
cause les principes de la déclaration de
droits de l'homme et des citoyens
y at il quelqu'un qui puisse considérer
ici qu'ils ne sont pas toujours moderne
qui ne sont pas toujours fondamentaux
que nous y sommes toujours attachés et
qu'il convient non seulement de les
défendre mais de faire en sorte qu'ils
vivent et qu'ils prospèrent
alors je crois que ce débat est très
important parce que le principe de 1945
ce qu'on nous dit j'ai entendu notre
collègue monsieur pignard dire les
choses ont changé on est plus en 1945
mais j'ai entendu il n'y a pas si
longtemps un président de la république
se référer les vous faire référer dans
toutes les écoles à monsieur guy môquet
bon alors on peut pas d'un côté dire 45
que ça existe plus
et puis quand ça arrange essayer de se
référer à cette période de la dernière
guerre donc je crois que ces principes
qui sont fondamentaux il faut savoir les
préserver les mineurs ils sont
différents mineurs ce sont nos jeunes
qui évoluent qui évoluent souvent
considérablement parfois dans le bon
sens parfois dans le mauvais sens et
qu'il faut une justice pénale
notre collègue jean pierre chevènement
parler des sauvageons peut pas dire
qu'il avait un discours laxistes il
avait le discours sage qui est celui à
la fois de la fermeté quand c'est
nécessaire et aussi de la compréhension
de la générosité parce que des enfants
s'agrandit ça a évolué et qu'il y a
besoin de procédures de système éducatif
quand on est dans une juridiction pour
enfants on voit quoi parce que j'entends
dire il faut aller vite il faut frapper
vite et pour certains fort pas tout ce
qui on le verra avec l'autre amendement
mais j'entends aussi et j'ai vu dans des
audiences de juge des enfants et de
tribunaux pour enfants
l'idée inverse de dire va écouter vous
êtes devant le tribunal vous êtes devant
moi le juge pour enfants très juge au
tribunal selon la procédure
eh bien écoutez on va voir comment vous
évoluez et puis vous reviendrez vous
reviendrez dans trois mois dans six mois
et là dans un an parfois et là bas nous
verrons si vous avez évolué
favorablement
et nous en tiendrons compte dans les
mesures que nous serons amenés à prendre
et c'est ça la sagesse c'est ça la
véritable sagesse et plus vous ramènerez
cette justice pour mineurs vers le
système de la justice pour majeur je
crois plus vous ferez une oeuvre
négative et puis nous le savons tous des
principes pour qu'ils soient bien
appliquées
il faut leur donner de bons moyens et
nous hiver reviendront quand nous
parlerons
jg merci s'il n'y a pas d'autres
demandes mais celle rapporteur
simplement pour dire que ce débat est un
débat tout à fait intéressant qui n'est
pas médiocre parfois peut-être un peu
manichéen
je me permettrai simplement de manière
très pratique de trois remarques et
trois points remarque très rapide
rassurez-vous la première remarque pour
dire que je ne suis pas convaincu que
l'extrême lenteur aujourd'hui de la
justice pénale des mineurs
souvenez vous des chiffres que nous
citions il ya 18 mois en moyenne en
matière de délit at entre la réponse
pénale et l'infraction
je ne suis pas convaincu que cette
lenteur soit particulièrement est
systématiquement favorable aux mineurs
en situation de délinquance je crois que
pédagogiquement effectivement ça mérite
qu'on y réfléchisse seconde remarque
pour dire que les infractions commises
par les mineurs et on parle ici de
délits ces infractions le réponse pénale
c'est quoi le réponse pénale c'est dans
la majorité des cas l'internet une
alternative aux poursuites dans un grand
nombre d'autres cas c'est la compétence
du juge des enfants cet étudiant en
audience de conseil et il n'y a que dans
un un cas un nombre de cas limités que
nous avons immédiatement la compétence
du tribunal pour enfants
et enfin dernière remarque je crois
qu'il est excessive de dire que le
tribunal pour enfants c'est l'alignement
du droit des mineurs sur le droit des
majeures le tribunal pour enfants il est
là pour appliquer le droit pénal des
mineurs et idées là pour faire respecter
la primauté notamment de l'éducatif sur
l'ascension merci pas d'autres demandes
d'intervention d'explications de vote je
fait voter sur ces trois amendements
identiques
quels sont ceux qui sont favorables à
leur adoption
ceux qui sont contre
ils ne sont pas adopté l'amendement 151
rectifier que présente monsieur des
prêts n'y si on lève la présidente lui
nous n'avons pas voté les amendements de
suppression de l'article 17 ne veut pas
dire que nous trouvons forcément que
l'article 17 est parfait tel qu'il nous
est présenté donc l'amendement 151 vise
à ce que la convocation par officier de
police judiciaire devant le tribunal
pour enfant ne soit pas applicable
un prix un mineur qui est primo
délinquants pour ce faire le dispositif
reprend une formulation identique à ce
qui avait été voté par le sénat lors de
l'examen de la loppsi 2 comme je les
râper lors de la discussion générale
hier je reste convaincue que le
mécanisme qui nous est présentée n'est
pas satisfaisant sur le fond notamment
notamment au regard du principe du
respect de la spécificité de la
procédure pénal applicable aux mineurs
et tout le monde convient qu'ils veulent
avoir effectivement des spécificités
dans la procédure pénale vis-à-vis des
mineurs pour autant cet amendement ne
remet pas en cause le principe de la
convocation par au pgi mineur il tend
simplement l'amendement numéro 151 il
tend simplement à limiter son
application à des mineurs qui ont déjà
été condamnés au moins une fois pour des
infractions similaires ou assimilé les
autres les primo délinquants doivent
d'abord être déféré devant le juge des
enfants
comme le prévoit la procédure actuelle
car ça a été dit dans le débat qui a eu
à l'instant un mineur
c'est pas un adulte en réduction même si
là si l'expression n'a pas été utilisé
saha mineurs on doit le considérer
surtout quand c'est la première
infraction qu'il fait on doit le
considérer différemment on considère un
adulte puis la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
les auteurs de l'amendement souhaite
restreindre la possibilité de convoquer
un mineur devant le tribunal pour
enfants aux mineurs récidivistes
cet amendement semble à la commission ad
probablement trop loin en effet s'il
n'est pas opportun d'utiliser cette
procédure lorsque le mineur n'a jamais
fait l'objet d'investigations
approfondies sur sa personnalité et le
texte de la commission à clarifier les
choses sur ce point l'amendement
interdirait dir écho d'y recourir par
exemple lorsque le mineur a précédemment
fait l'objet de mesures éducatives ou
qu'il a précédemment été condamné pour
une infraction d'une autre nature
il semble à la commission que le critère
essentiel permettant d'envisager le
renvoi du mineur directement devant le
tribunal pour enfants sans passer par
une phase d'instruction préalable devant
le juge des enfants et le caractère
complet des informations dont la
juridiction disposera lui permettant de
statuer en pleine connaissance de cause
je rappellerai enfin que stricto sensu
seuls 1,5 pour cent des infractions
commises par des mineurs sont commises
en état de récidive légale
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans sa
majorité la commission a donné un avis
défavorable
merci l'avis du gouvernement mais c'est
le garde des sceaux
merci bab la présidente sur l'amendement
qu'elle vient de présenter monsieur
détraigne parce que je dois suivre
l'avis du rapporteur sur d'autres
abonnements qu'il présentera ensuite
d'autres avis pourront être données je
crois qu'un exigent que les mineurs
doivent avoir est déjà été condamné pour
des infractions similaires ou assimilé
cet amendement réduit considérablement
le champ de la convocation par opg ne
permettent pas de prendre en
considération le phénomène que les
praticiens connaissent bien qui est
celui des adolescents qu'ils ont un bref
laps de temps quelques semaines parfois
deux ou trois mois comme est une série
d'infractions souvent de plus en plus
graves et dans ses hypothèses de recours
à la convocation par au pgi est tout à
fait pertinent parce qu'il permet
d'obtenir un jugement rapide qui pourra
mettre fin à cette spirale délinquance
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
pour cette raison je demande options de
trane de bien vouloir retirer son
amendement bénéfice des suivants
détraigne j'ai écouté attentivement le
rapporteur et et le ministre je suis
prêt à retirer ces amendements mais je
précise que derrière il ya d'autres
amendements qui accommodent la procédure
donc je viens d'entendre un instant que
le garde des sceaux me demandait de
retirer cet amendement au bénéfice des
suivantes donc je n'oublie pas la fin de
la phrase soon hanks ou sousse avec son
mémoire ce que vient de dire le garde
des sceaux je retire l'amendement 151
merci l'amendement 154 monsieur
détraigne 154 rectifier alors nous
sommes toujours sur la procédure de
convocation par au pgi mineurs donc
l'amendement en 154 lui tend à prévoir
que cette procédure ne puisse être mise
en oeuvre que si le mineur a déjà fait
l'objet d'une où plusieurs procédures en
application des dispositions de
l'ordonnancé de 45
le critère d'application est donc
sensiblement différent de celui que je
viens de proposer il y à quelques
minutes avec l'amendement précédentes
puisqu'il ne s'applique plus
exclusivement sur la notion de mineur
condamné pour des infractions similaires
en effet les délais de jugement étant
malheureusement assez long ce qui ne
sera peut-être plus le cas demain
monsieur ministre puisque c'est l'un des
objectifs de la réforme
il peut arriver qu'à un mineur soit déjà
largement connus de la justice
sans pour autant avoir été encore
condamné le critère proposés et doper
ainsi que celui de la condamnation mais
l'objectif reste atteint puisqu'il
s'agit d' exclure de cette procédure
un mineur qui ne seraient pas encore
connue par la justice merci l'avis de la
commission monsieur reporter la
commission a souhaité sur cet amendement
s'en remettre à l'avis du gouvernement
l'avis du gouvernement monsieur le garde
des sceaux merci mme la présidente
pour cet événement 154 rectifier le
gouvernement donnera un avis favorable
cette précision vient utilement
compléter le texte de la commission des
lois et apporter une correction
nécessaire qui figurait pas dans le
texte initial du gouvernement
vous voyez je suis toujours attentif aux
débats constructifs que l'on peut mener
avec le sénat et grâce à cet amendement
la convocation par officier de police
judiciaire ne sera jamais délivré un
primo délinquant
pour autant il sera possible de délivrer
cette convocation à l'encontre de ces
mineurs qui commettent des faits à
répétition dans un bref laps de temps
je suis donc favorable comme je le
disais merci je vais donc faire voter
sur cet amendement 154 et eefje ceux qui
sont favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre ou qu'ils
s'abstiennent
il est adopté trois amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune à
l'article 17 donc c'est le l'amendement
156 qui est présenté par le gouvernement
merci même la présidente en donnant un
avis favorable à l'amendement 154 de
monsieur detraigne une partie de
l'amendement que le gouvernement
souhaitait déposer est satisfaite la
première partie est satisfaite par cet
amendement pour la seconde partie les
relatives au recueil de renseignements
socio éducatif je pense qu'en fait état
de la discussion devant le parlement et
les mieux de retirer cet amendement
l'avis de la commission 150 rectifié
monsieur détraigne oui merci madame la
présidente donc je vous présente le 150
l'article 17 du texte prévoit donc la
convocation par au pgi ne peut être
délivré que si des investigations sur
les faits ne sont pas nécessaires et si
des investigations sur la personnalité
du mineur ont été accomplis au cours des
12 mois précédant notre amendement
l'amendement 150 que je vous présente
s'attache à cette deuxième condition
celle des 12 mois précédents il a pour
objet de s'assurer du caractère
suffisamment récent des informations
relatives à la personnalité du mineur
car le mineur évidemment il bouge il
bouge
rappelons que c'est justement ce qui
justifie usage de cette procédure qui
reste dérogatoires en matière de mineurs
le texte ouvre la possibilité de prendre
en compte des informations sur le mineur
qui remonteraient à près d'un an alors
que ça suty situation a pu largement
évoluer dans un tel délai et cette
évolution peut avoir été aussi bien
positives que négatives aussi le présent
amendement vise à réduire le délai de 12
mois à 6 mois
il est en effet nous semble-t-il normale
et efficace de pouvoir utiliser les
informations qui ont pu être réunis sur
le mineur au cours des procédures
précédentes surtout avec le dossier
unique de personnalité qui permet
effectivement d'avoir une vision plus
complète de la personnalité du mineur
mais il est indispensable de ne pas
pouvoir s'appuyer sur des informations
trop
ancien et potentiellement obsolète ne
prenons pas en considération les
évolutions récentes exigé que les
informations sur le mineur soit récent
permettra justement de s'assurer d'un
passage devant le juge des enfants
lorsque cela est nécessaire voilà pour
l'amendement 150 153 rectifié monsieur
yves règne alors le 153 est un
amendement qui se situe dans le
prolongement de ce que je vous ai
proposé avec les amendements précédente
il s'agit de s'assurer que les
informations relatives à la personnalité
du mineur qui sont prises en compte sont
limitées à celles qui proviennent de la
sphère pénale en effet la fin du
cinquième alinéa de l'article 17 prévoit
la possibilité de prendre en compte des
investigations et réalisé par un juge
des enfants statuant en matière
d'assistance éducative
or cette dernière mission relève du
domaine civil et non du domaine pénal
nous vous proposons donc de supprimer
cette disposition au travers de
l'amendement 153 merci quel avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur alors
sur le 150 ratifié madame la présidente
en exigeant des investigations réalisées
au cours des six mois précédents au lieu
des douze mois actuellement prévue par
le projet de loi l'amendement de nos
collègues introduirait une conditions
plus restrictives pour rocco pour
recourir à la convocation par officier
de police judiciaire devant le tribunal
pour enfants que pour recourir à la
procédure de présentation immédiate
alors qu'il s'agit d'une procédure moins
restrictive de liberté
il n'est pas prévu de placement sous
contrôle judiciaire ou en détention
provisoire du mineur
en attendant l'audience de jugement la
distorsion ne paraît pas à la commission
justifiée d'autant que s'agissant de la
présentation immédiate le conseil
constitutionnel a validé le délai d'un
an
donc la vie sur le 150 rectifié est un
avis défavorable sur le 153 rectifier la
commission s'en remettra à l'avis du
gouvernement l'avis du gouvernement mais
c'est le garde des sceaux sur ces deux
amendements
merci ma présidence s'agissant de la
bande mon numéro 150
le gouvernement partage la vie
de la commission le délai de six mois
est un délai trop court dans le temps
judiciaire
le conseil constitutionnel vient de
valider et le délai est d'un an je crois
donc qu'il faut s'y tenir et de plus le
recueil de renseignements socio éducatif
qui est activé en permanence sera là
pour fournirait les derniers
renseignements si cela est nécessaire
sur les éléments de personnalité
j'ai donc si de treignes les co
signataires de l'amendement de peu qu'il
retire cet amendement est par contre le
gouvernement est favorable à
l'amendement numéro 153
merci monsieur et rhein sur le 150 est
ce que vous maintenez votre amendement
compte tenu des explications qui
viennent d'être données de la position
que j'ai prise par le conseil
constitutionnel je retire donc
l'amendement 150 bien alors je vais
faire voter sur le 153 rectifié qui a
reçu un accueil favorable et de la
commission et du gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont favorables à
son adoption il est adopté à l'unanimité
ai je fait voter sur l'article 17 ceux
qui sont d'accord pour l'article 17
ceux qui sont contre il est adopté
l'article 29 une demande de parole de
me2
madame boumédiene thiery ah pardon
pardon madame la présidente
oui je crois que cet article 29 est
vraiment le le le signe de la
déstructuration de la justice des
mineurs est alors comme tout à l'heure
je ne suis pas intervenu parce que je
l'avais je venais de le faire je n'ai
pas pu reprendre la parole quand
d'aucuns se référer à 1945 d'une façon
bien entendu que je ne peux approuver
puisque j'ai souvent dit ici que tout a
changé depuis et que nous même ne sommes
plus le législateur de 1945
1 vous le savez donc que tout le monde a
grandi en taille bonfim bref il ya tout
ça enfin papa moi parce qu'elle ment
mais d'autres notamment les chaînes tous
les jeunes
donc tout ça évidemment est prête à rire
quoi si ce n'est à pleurer donc par
contre est quelque chose qui m'étonne
toujours c'est que ceux qui veulent
absolument nous dire que l' ordonnance
de 40 c'est que 1945 n'était plus n'est
plus aujourd'hui devrait quand même
réfléchir au fait que depuis c'est à
dire bien postérieurement à 1945
il ya eu un certain nombre de
dispositions internationales
oui qui étaient postérieurs alors je
vais pas dire mais la france était en
avance oui quelque part en tout cas dans
ce domaine la france l'époque et depuis
il ya eu la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant
la préconisation de pékin et voyez je
trouve que cette année est mauvaise
quand même pour la france puisque on a
trouvé le moyen nous de supprimer le
défenseur des enfants qui est préconisé
justement par la convention
internationale des droits de l'homme des
droits de l'enfant pardon et qui en plus
existe de plus en plus dans de nombreux
pays
eh bien nous on le supprime et puis
maintenant et bien on va supprimer en
quelque sorte enfin en tout cas mettre
le pied dans la la casse de la
spécificité de la justice des mineurs
alors que des pays voisins comme cela a
été dit au contraire ont tendance à
étendre les procédures des mineurs au
delà de l'âge de 18 ans alors qu'ils
sont grosso modo autant de problèmes
divers
d'ailleurs avec dans la jeunesse alors
moi je vais vous citer l'unicef bon
l'unicef c'est pas une organisation
politique quand même un monde est
d'accord alors l'unicef a critiqué
beaucoup le projet votre projet
mais elle donne un certain nombre de
préconisations de recommandation alors
elle dit il faut d'abord il faut éviter
une stigmatisation des jeunes c'est raté
c'est raté depuis cinq ans vous
n'arrêtez pas de montrer du doigt les
jeunes et même à l'âge de 3 ans et même
avant
et oui mais c'est vrai ensuite elle dit
faut préférer le terrain enfants à celui
de mineurs
raté considérer les mineurs dangereux
d'abord comme des enfants en danger
c'est raté défendre les grands principes
de l'ordonance de 45 et surtout en
préserver l'esprit c'est raté parce que
vous ne conservez pas du tout l'esprit
puisque vous
la spécificité vous essayez de nous
expliquer que la spécificité oui vous
êtes toujours une spécificité attention
à partir du moment où on casse l'unité
du tribunal fait de l'ensemble du juge
et tribunal pour enfants ont créé en
plus un tribunal correctionnel pour
enfants tous pas semblable au tribunal
correctionnel pour les majeurs on n'est
plus dans les principes fixés l'âge de
la responsabilité pénale au dessus du
seuil de l'inacceptable voyez il ya des
pays considérés quand même la majorité
des pays européens c'est plutôt 14 et
plus donc là aussi on n'est pas vraiment
d'un coup des formes d'injustice
spécialisé jusqu'à 18 ans au moment où
vous apprêtez à faire de l'injustice non
spécifiques à partir de 16 ans donc
encore une fois c'est raté déployer les
moyens nécessaires on aura l'occasion
d'en parler quand on voit la misère de
la pjj par exemple soutenir les parents
plutôt que les accabler c'est le
contraire encore une fois c'est pas bon
on n'arrête pas de les culpabiliser et
en plus vous savez certains s'insurgent
contre tous ces gens qui vivent de
l'assistance sociale
enfin instaurer une politique volontaire
de prévention de la jeunesse et vous ne
répondez la prévention ça suffit j'ai
entendu maintenant c'est la sanction
donc encore une fois c'est raté voilà et
ça c'est je trouve que c'est très
dommage parce que on a en quelque sorte
été initiateur de principe qui ô combien
généreux pour la jeunesse qui ont été
repris sur le plan international au fil
du temps et dieu sait s'il ya beaucoup à
faire encore bien sûr et nous ont fait
nous vous fait marche arrière
voilà et donc vous avez encore une fois
vous avez voulu nous prouver que vous
étiez tout à fait dans les clous et bien
un nombre bien non parce que vous
modifiez la procédure de la justice des
mineurs puisque le conseil
constitutionnel vous a parlé des deux
est la procédure et les tribunaux eh
bien vous modifiez les deux vous
rapprocher la procédure de celle des
majeurs et vous casser le tribunal pour
enfants pour en faire deux instances
différentes
regardez le tribunal pour en forme ce
serait évidemment difficile de rayer de
la carte et vous créez un tribunal
correctionnel pour mineurs qui va juger
beaucoup beaucoup d'infractions commises
par les mineurs sous une forme qui
évidemment ressemble comme deux gouttes
d'eau à la justice les majeures merci
madame viviane thiry
oui monsieur ministre en effet votre
article 29 propose de créer une nouvelle
juridiction spécialisée compétente pour
juger les mineurs récidivistes de plus
de 16 ans j'ai l'impression que l'on
veut fait non seulement dans le droit
spécialisé mais aussi en plus dans la
juridiction d'exception
en effet il s'agit une nouvelle fois de
la reprise d'une des propositions issues
du rapport varinard
cette nouvelle juridiction réservée aux
jeunes récidivistes de 16 à 18 ans place
le juge des enfants en minorité dans
cette nouvelle composition ou des juges
une issue du tribunal correctionnel
seront dès lors majoritaire
pour nous cet article constitue une
nouvelle manifestation de défiance du
gouvernement à l'égard du juge des
enfants soupçonnés à tort de laxisme
dans le traitement de leur dossier
ces mesures accable évidemment également
les assesseurs qui accompagne le juge
des enfants le fait que le juge des
enfants précis président
cette nouvelle composition des cas leur
il ne suffit évidemment pas à remédier
aux lacunes évidentes et à la
dangerosité d'une telle disposition
il s'agit évidemment d'une atteinte
inconstitutionnelle au principe de la
juridiction spécialisée qui par ailleurs
à l'horizon de travail pédagogique fait
par le juge des enfants
une fois plus longtemps ici à traiter
les mineurs comme des adultes
délinquants en les faisant passer devant
une juridiction semblable à celle des
majeurs comme si cela suffisait à les
dissuader à terme de récidive est de
nouveau or il n'en sera rien ces
dispositions ne tient absolument pas
compte de la complexité des situations
de délinquance juvénile
je rappellerai rappellerait ici les
exigences de l'article 1er de
l'ordonance de 45 qui disposent les
mineurs auxquels est imputé une
infraction qualifiée de crime ou délit
ne seront pas déférer aux juridictions
pénales de droit commun et seront
justifiable de que des tribunaux pour
enfants ou des cours d'assises de
mineurs
la composition de ces nouveaux tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs dont vous
tenter enfin de nous faire les louanges
monsieur ministre ne garantit donc en
rien la spécialisation de la justice des
mineurs
puisqu'un seul juge pour enfants est
arrivé ici à siéger aux côtés de deux
magistrats qui eux ne seront pas
spécialisés
pire encore que l'expérimentation qui
sera fait dès 1er janvier 2012 dans les
cours d'appel en deux citoyens
assesseurs accompagneront les trois
magistrats dans les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs à l'instar
du tribunal correctionnel pour majeur
vous préférez donc monsieur ministre aux
assesseurs choisi pour l'intérêt qu'ils
portent questions de l'enfance et pour
leurs compétences qui exercent au sein
du tribunal pour enfants
deux jurés populaires formé à la va-vite
dont il n'est pas qu'ils dont il n'est
pas exigé un quelconque intérêt pour les
problématiques spécifiques des mineurs
malheureusement cet article 29 est une
nouvelle illustration de d'idées reçues
rabattu 116 par le gouvernement est
dénoncée à maintes reprises durant notre
discussion générale selon laquelle les
mineurs d'aujourd'hui ne seraient pas
ceux d'hier
il est éminemment regrettable que ce
poncif erronée et guider le contenu de
cet article
ainsi que toute la rédaction du titre ii
du présent projet de loi pose tout
ces raisons bien sûr nous voterons
massivement contre l'article 29
merci nous abordons maintenant trois
amendements identiques faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 41 monsieur michel où
monsieur diani madame la présidente
cet article est important puisse y créer
ce fameux si bien avec correctionnel
pour les mineurs auquel nous sommes
opposés
je vais vous expliquer quels sont pour
nous les trois défauts majeurs de ce
tribunal
mais d'abord je voudrais reprendre la
discussion
quelle est la raison de la création de
ce tribunal moi j'ai lu le rapport de
jeu le serbe
j'ai regardé d'étude d'impact j'ai
entendu de tout à l'heure virginie klès
il n'y a pas d'éléments statistiques qui
nous permettent de considérer
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en face d'une
délinquance des mineurs qui auraient un
caractère évolutif notamment tel qu'il
faudrait prendre de nouvelles mesures
pour enrayer nous savons que la
délinquance des mineurs évolue
sensiblement parallèlement à celle des
majeurs et donc là il n'ya pas
d'originalité
alors qu'elles sont pour nous les trois
défauts le premier défaut évidemment
c'est que le tribunal correctionnel des
mineurs ni la spécificité du mineur on
va pas le développer mais il nie dans
l'essentiel puisque avant il y avait des
assesseurs qui avait devait avoir une
qualification un intérêt précise pour
les questions de la jeunesse demain y en
aura plus donc on fait disparaître la
spécificité
j'ai entendu là sur les banques quelques
explications nous disons toujours la
même chanson c'est à dire oui mais les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne sont plus comme
les jeunes d'avant je ferai quand même
observer que nous sommes peut-être les
seuls en europe à le penser
cela a été dit mais je voudrais donner
quelques détails parce que j'étais
regarder à l'instant la note de synthèse
publiée sur le site du sénat sur cette
question et dans la note de synthèse on
lit des choses tout à fait intéressante
puisqu'on dit que quel est le mouvement
aujourd'hui européen en allemagne le
droit des mineurs est applicable aux
jeunes de 18 à 21 ans mais il n'y a pas
que l'allemagne en fait
au portugal c'est la même chose pour
pays bas c'est la même chose et en
espagne où
aujourd'hui il ya effectivement un
régime applicable à partir de 18 ans on
considère qu'il faut aller au delà et le
porter à saison aujourd'hui est allé au
delà elle portait aujourd'hui à 18 ans
c'est à dire que dans la plupart des
pays européens on considère qu
effectivement le jeune d'aujourd'hui
départ le même que le jeune de 1945 mais
que justement d'une certaine façon c'est
prérogatives de la jeunesse doit être
assurée au delà de 18 ans et regardons
21 ans nous sommes tous européens se
garent dépôt alors des gardes des sceaux
alors justement tirons gens là une leçon
en la matière et essayons de nous
aligner sur les autres pays européens
deuxième des fauches c'est très bref
basse et l'automaticité du renvoi des
mineurs récidivistes
là évidemment on a tout de suite peur
avec la notion de récidive mais ça veut
dire quoi
c'est à dire que le mineur qui a volé
des bonbons un jour à l'étal d'un
marchand et qui demain va se retrouver
en état de recel par exemple d'un dvd et
bien va se retrouver en état de récidive
et comme il se retrouve en état de
récidive alors il va être directement
il va directement comparaître devant le
tribunal pour enfants et puis le
troisième des faux évidemment c'est le
fait qu' on ne change pas simplement
tribunal on change d'aproz on change
approche est effectivement on va vers
une approche qui est conforme à celle
des majeurs tout cela évidemment ne peut
pas nous convenir merci l'amendement 88
que madame oui merci madame la
présidente donc céder c'est vrai cet
article est important mais je voudrais
dire surtout qu'il est qu'il est
redoutable car n'en déplaise à certains
ici il
il détruit effectivement des principes
fondateurs et fondamentaux de
l'ordonance de 45 relative à l'enfance
délinquante
donc j il me semble que aujourd'hui le
le gouvernement fait fi du principe
constitutionnel de spécialisation de la
justice des mineurs
car en réalité le tribunal correctionnel
pour mineurs étant presque tous points
identiques donc à celle des majeurs donc
ce principe de spécialisation de la
justice des mineurs des mineurs n'est
pas seulement garantis par la
constitution il l'est également et cela
a été rappelé notamment par nicole borvo
cohen seat par des textes internationaux
on a évoqué donc l'article 40 de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant
mais de même que les règles de pékin sur
le traitement des mineurs délinquants
qui a été adoptée par les nations unies
et qui garantissent ces droits de
l'enfant par ailleurs et pour y avoir
travaillé quand même
je rappelle ici que le conseil
constitutionnel donc dans sa décision du
10 mars a invalidé plusieurs
dispositions relatives à la justice des
mineurs qui étaient donc inséré dans la
loppsi 2 en rappelant la nécessité de
respect de la spécialisation de la
justice des mineurs tentant de se
prémunir évidemment contre les critiques
d'inconstitutionnalité qu'on ne manquera
pas de lui objecter et pour cause ce
texte de loi prévoit donc une
soi-disante procédures spécifiques qui
se résume à la seule présidence du
triple de ce dribble tribunal par le
juge pour enfant aux côtés de deux
magistrats non spécialisés alors qu'on
sait très bien que le président ne
dispose d'aucun pouvoir particulier donc
cette disposition et d'une ignorance
totale
la spécificité de la justice des mineurs
ne tient pas à la seule présence du juge
pour enfants elle n'est spécialisés que
si de sa prise en charge en passant par
son jugement
et pour aller jusqu'au prononcé des
peines le mineur est suivie et suivie
selon une procédure hausse
fyk par une institution consacrée et
selon des mesures adaptées tout le
processus fait sens ainsi cet article ni
le travail pédagogique du juge pour
enfants dénigrent la phase pré
sentenciel dont l'importance est
primordial pour la préhension et la
compréhension par le mineur du jugement
et de la peine il porte en lui la fin de
la justice pour des mineurs qui ne sont
effectivement plus les mêmes qui hier
il instaure donc une marginalisation des
tribunaux pour enfants enfin dernière
chose ce tribunal correctionnel pour
mineurs et d'une accords et incohérence
totale
il pourra être composé de citoyens
assesseurs non spécialisés alors qu'au
sein du tribunal pour enfants sièges
deux assesseurs choisi pour l'intérêt
qu'il porte aux questions de l'enfance
et en fonction de leurs compétences dans
ce domaine
si monsieur merci vous qui défendez
l'amendement 147 rectifier oui madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues
effectivement cet article 29 et un d
aussi un des points forts un de ce texte
est la création du tribunal
correctionnel pour mineurs
si l'on en croit l'exposé des motifs est
justifiée par la nécessité de faire
comprendre aux intéressés la nécessité
de sortir de l'engrenage de la
délinquance alors passons l'angélisme
le postulat c'est que il faut réprimer
et
pour nous c'est une nouvelle brèche cet
article 29 dans la spécificité du droit
pénal des mineurs
l'oralité des débats y compris en séance
publique au sénat c'est bien mais il est
toujours très intéressant d'aller lire
ce que vous avez écrit et j'ai le projet
de loi sous les yeux et j'y vois à la
page 83
très objectivement relater ce que vous
voulez vous dites que cette création de
ce tribunal correctionnel pour mineurs
c'est la préconisation de la commission
varinard
et quel est le but à la progressivité
des sanctions doit correspondre une même
progression dans les formations de
jugement compétent pour connaître des
mineurs jusqu'à afficher une plus grande
sévérité avec la comparution du mineur
devant un tribunal correctionnel dont la
charge symbolique et la solennité
apparaissent nécessairement plus forte
et je tourne la page et je vois que il
faut effectivement cette option pour
vous pour tourner le problème de la
spécialisation des juridictions des
mineurs aussi la composition de la
juridiction de droit commun je vous cite
a été adaptée afin de prévoir la
présence d'au moins un juge des enfants
le renvoi de certains mineurs dans cette
juridiction présente l'avantagé de
permettre dans ces cas de juger
également des coauteurs et complices
majeur ça aussi c'est tout à fait
révélateur bon et que je vais au bout en
bout de ce paragraphe il paraissait donc
assez justifiée que ces mineurs qui
peuvent se voir infliger des peines
suivant le régime applicable aux majeurs
comparaissent également devant une
juridiction propre aux majeurs parce
qu'en effet les mineurs de plus de 16
ans compte une situation particulière
dans notre ordre juridique puisque pour
ces mineurs l'excusé de minorité peut
être écarté à titre exceptionnel
mais on vous fait confiance pour que
l'exceptionnel dérive vers l'habituel
donc vous avez dans ces deux pages la
caractérisation des buts réels que vous
poursuivez c'est vous qu'il écrivait
voilà quelle est la réalité
et alors on va avoir un tribunal
correctionnel des mineurs avec un seul
juge des enfants
vous remplacez les deux juges qui
étaient des personnes d'expérience dans
le domaine des enfants par deux juges
professionnels
on voit mal la quel est le but poursuivi
est vous y ajoutez dans certains cas
deux citoyens assesseurs qui bien
évidemment n'auront eux strictement sauf
cas exceptionnel
aucune compétence particulière dans ce
domaine particulier et pour couronner le
tout et j'en termine
l'alinéa dose dit que le service de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse est
consulté nous savons quel est l'état de
la pjj
malheureusement et malheureusement aussi
du grand manque de moyens qui
caractérise aujourd'hui la pjj
merci nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance
pour la revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
bonne fin de journée à tous